a hearing on the delta variant takes a
turn when senator rand paul and dr
anthony fauci go head to head
again over the wuhan lab
dr fauci knowing that it is a crime to
lie to congress
do you wish to retract your statement of
may 11 where you claimed that the nih
never funded gain of function research
in wuhan senator paul
i have never lied before the congress
and i do not retract that statement you
do not know what you are talking about
gain of function research was going on
in that lab and nih funded it
that is night away from it it meets your
definition and you are
obfuscating the truth i'm not
obfuscating the truth
you are implying that what we did
was responsible for the deaths of
individual
i totally resent that and if anybody is
lying
here senator it is you answer the
question
did you fund gain a function research in
the woohon lab
here to react former white house
coronavirus task force testing czar
admiral brett gerard
admiral what should we know about that
exchange
um i think it was a concerning exchange
and and i do believe
probably dr fauci was hiding behind the
technical definitions of what the nih
might consider
quote gain of function research but what
they did
fund was exactly what rand paul said
they funded researchers to go in the
hundreds of miles away into the back of
bat caves
extract dangerous viruses from bats that
have never been seen by humans before
and bring them to a city of 10 million
people in the wuhan lab
next they chopped up those viruses and
created new frankenstein viruses
to see if they could infect human cells
now that may not
technically be quote gain of function
research but it is dangerous research
and senator paul's questions deserve to
be answered
and if i were a betting man and i'm not
but i would bet all those viruses
got immediately channeled into the
chinese bio weapons program
with the chinese military that we know
we're operating at the wuhan lab
legitimate questions i didn't think we
got a legitimate answer you
you worked with senator uh you worked
with dr thatcher have you
ever seen him so rattled or
inappropriate
in a senate hearing no i really haven't
he he's usually
pretty cool in those hearings and and i
was really concerned
because i don't think that posture was
good for him
good for the hearing or good to inspire
confidence in the american people
look i was in that chair senator murray
senator warren
beat us up in the trump administration
but you take it respectfully that's part
of the process
i have never ever seen and i hope it
never happens again
that a witness who's a public health
official calls a u.s
senator a liar and doesn't know what he
was talking about when clearly senator
paul
read the paper and had important points
to be made so he
did fund gain of function research right
well you know i don't know what the nih
considers i describe the research
it is clearly dangerous concerning
research
if you know this originated from a bat
cave why would we
go out and look for trouble and bring it
to a city of 10 million people then chop
that virus up so
you know there's probably legal
definitions of what it is or what it
isn't
but the point is this research um was
potentially dangerous research that
brought dangerous viruses in
chopped them up made new viruses and
looked at their infectivity
now to me that's gain of function
research or could lead directly to gain
a function research
but under any definition that's
something that needs to be investigated
congress in a bipartisan way needs to
completely open the komona
on nih research and their accountability
for that research
problem is one side is not curious and i
don't get it admiral admiral gerard
thanks so much
thank you hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube
so subscribe right now